CBS News contributor Bob Schieffer
covered George Bush's presidential
campaigns in 1980 and 1988 the longtime
moderator of Face the Nation is here
with USA Today Washington bureau chief
Susan page who also covered the bush
campaigns her upcoming book is called
the matriarch Barbara Bush and the
making of an American dynasty looking
forward to that book Bob you think about
the 11 presidencies you've covered is
that right and I know that you have said
the President George HW Bush was one of
the most modest presidents ever if not
the most well he Wallace I mean when you
stop and think about it I mean he didn't
even feel it was appropriate to write a
book at the end of his presidency how
many presidents in modern times can you
remember that that took that point of
view and and he just it was part of his
upbringing his family his mother had
beaten into those children that look we
don't brag on things we do which is why
I've always thought he was a much better
public servant than he was a politician
he just never was comfortable you know
promoting himself one of his other
attributes was these handwritten notes
which I had heard about that he would
keep a stack of them even in the
presidential limo that he was always
writing notes and you received one of
his notes Susan what was it about well
in 1990 a White House press conference
he called on me he pointed at me and
said and you have a question and and of
course my name wasn't an and February's
name was Ann and Debra was at the
Washington Post reporter was a couple
seats away but he was clearly calling me
so I asked a question and then he worked
my name into his response so and I blah
blah blah and this and so there was this
laughter that was rising up with my
colleagues because he kept calling me
Ann and so when he left the press
conference he said to Marlin Fitzwater
specific Jerry why were they laughing
and he said her name's not Ann her
name's Susan and then he wrote the next
day this beautiful no derives his
handwritten note from President Bush
saying I know you're not an and Margaret
lives on the west coast but I forgot so
classic George Bush in that was very
Curt no need I took no offense no need
for him to write it he does this corny
joke about Ann Margaret and so of course
I had this framed and hanging on my wall
at home of course yeah Bob this humility
that you're talking about you know when
he used to talk about his face
years he would say I when he talked
about the successive administration he
used to say we the reason this is
important is because it it helps in a
White House right when when you create
this sense of team and and people around
you feel like you're all together well
exactly and and you know he was so
restrained I mean to me the great mark
of his presidency was the restraint he
exercised that very crucial junctures of
American history when the Berlin Wall
fell for example he refused to brag
about it he refused to to let anybody
else brag about it and I talked to his
son George W Bush one time about that
and I said why was he that way and he
said he had this tremendous ability to
put himself in the other guys shoes and
he wanted he knew he was gonna need
Gorbachev's cooperation when when
communism collapsed and that's why he
exercised that restraint he did the same
thing in that tienamin square
he didn't say anything in the beginning
but then a couple of months later he
sent Brent Scowcroft to to Beijing and
he laid down the law he said look we
can't get get along with you this is how
it's gonna be I think one of things
people may not know about him although
we've we've mentioned it and certainly
did again on 60 minutes but here he is
18 years old and enlists in the Navy his
father the senator Prescott Bush does
not he wants him to go to Yale and
instead he becomes he flies combat
missions is almost killed he had this
sense he said it was the only time he
saw his father cry when he went off to
war that sense of duty honor he was our
last president who served in combat
no no question about his determination
to enlist he considered in fact
enlisting in the Canadian Air Force
because they would take you at 17
instead of 18 he waited until he
graduated from prep school took the
train with his father down to New York
enlisted he was always sensitive Barbara
Bush told me he was sensitive about the
fact that he was so young he was either
the youngest or one of the youngest Navy
pilots ever and that when she came to
visit him once in in when he was being
trained that he wanted her to lie about
her age
to add a year so that his colleagues
would not think he was such a kid and
you know Nora we when we talk about his
combat we talked about when he was shot
down over the Pacific but the fact is he
flew 58 combat missions on your fire and
again he never talked about it very much
he didn't like to because he he always
remembered his two crew members who died
when the plane was shot down and that
was a part that he always taking off and
landing on aircraft carrier yeah that's
what the idea that they always
challenged his manliness the guy who
flew that many missions back down and
then jumped out of a plane he was doing
fine yeah Bob Schieffer Susan page thank
you not to be confused with him